now a year ago we sat down in hastings
when you kicked off your
tour of the uk trying to effectively
canvas opinions and
options for your next manifesto now
we're here in stroud
succinctly what's the message that
you've been hearing
investment we've got to invest to grow
the economy investment investment
investment all the way through but um
in places like this in particular we've
been getting that this has to be
investment for a purpose
and it's about attacking climate change
green industrial
revolution addressing regional
inequalities in particular
and then rebuilding our public services
that have been cut back from austerity
and the message is similar throughout
the country and
i've been doing every other saturday for
a year on this but people have different
ideas about
what's happening in their local area so
they're saying actually we want the
power ourselves
locally to deliver these places by
christmas
there could be john mcdonald chancellor
in number 11.
what's your radical agenda i mean is
capitalism working
not effectively as people as we've seen
all around the country really the
grotesque levels of inequality
five million children in prospect of
being in poverty two-thirds of those in
households where someone's at work
are public services i'll just give one
example the report two months ago
87 people dying a day before they
receive the social care that they need
so the issue is this just because of not
enough money going in or is it the
system that's broken that's what's a
combination it's a combination of both
um first of all it isn't enough money
going in we need a fair taxation system
but we also need a growing economy we
need investment in our infrastructure
and skills
to enable us to have an economy that
will
distribute wealth effectively and fairly
across our society
you know such regional inequality is
holding
local areas back in developing their
local economy for example
one area where many people feel
capitalism and the society really isn't
working as housing
um you've got an awful lot of young
people and lots of young people who are
struggling to get on the housing ladder
um i think it's perhaps difficult to
really invest in capitalism believe in
capitalism you don't have capital
yourself
what's your radical plan for housing
three issues there one
is the state has to play a role so it
does mean
councils building council houses again
so first of all we've said we'll build a
million
new homes half of them will be council
homes in the short term though as well
we've got to recognize there's a large
number of people out there in the
private sector
who have been charged high rents some of
them being ripped off as well
so in some areas it will be empowering
councils to introduce fair rents
but the third issue as well is actually
saying to the private sector how can we
work together
to make sure the investment that's
coming from the productive elements of
the economy
yes is going back into rebuilding our
manufacturing base
tackling the fourth industrial
revolution making sure it's a green
industrial revolution
but also making sure that there's
investment in housing
but that housing has to be housing for
the future so
in other words it's about housing that
will help us tackle climate change
rather than contribute to it it feels
sometimes like labor at the minute very
good at pinpointing the problems but
it's just the solutions that
the difficult yeah and although you know
i appreciate that you're saying you want
to build more homes more council claims
i mean this is stuff we've heard from
politicians before isn't it by doing
these meetings these town meetings all
over the country
you recognize the solution is in the
hands of local people we're saying to
people
we'll draft our manifesto from the grass
roots upwards
but what we want you to do is get a
local manifesto trauma as well so when
we hit the deck running
when we have a fair taxation system when
we're investing and growing our economy
the resources will then be released
to enable you to solve the problems at
your local level it will be local people
that will lead this transformation
one um report that you've commissioned
land for the many uh it says that it
would recommend
um scrapping inheritance tax and
replacing it with like a lifetime gifts
tax so you're attracted to that idea
we're looking at it um it might be one
of those ideas and we're consulting on
at the moment
are you trying to interest do you like
the idea i think it's interesting we
need to have a fairer system
of how we can ensure that wealth is more
fairly distributed
that's one idea and yes we're listening
we're listening to a whole range of
ideas
how about the idea of um capital gains
tax being introduced
when you sell a house so effectively any
profit that you make you get taxed on
we haven't we haven't really looked at
that because we feel that most probably
won't be the fairest way of going about
it
but we have looked at capital gains tax
reforms with regard to shareholders and
others and that will be part of the
debate that we have around taxation so
it sounds like you're a bit keener on
the lifetime
gift tax perhaps not quite so keen on
the cattle for instance on the lifetime
gift tax we're consulting
that's it and what we'll do is in the
normal way completely open and
transparently consult
publish the responses that we come back
come to our conclusions and then have
that debate
democratic debate than the party about
what goes into the manifesto you also
sparked a bit of a reaction this week
when you talked about de-listing
companies on the london stock exchange
if you don't feel that they're
effectively stepping up when it comes to
the environment
what's that about okay it's like this
look we do we've got through parliament
the declaration of a climate emergency
and i congratulate people like extension
rebellion i'm wearing their
sticker today they've put climate change
at the top of our agenda so it's the
priority for the next
labour government basically and what
we're saying is we have to harness all
our resources
so in the speech i laid out all the
state resources that we made available
i also said we need private sector
resources to do that here's how we'll
attract them and manage them but also
we've got to ensure that there's proper
regulation of activity as well
we've got to have a just transition from
a fossil fuel economy
to a net zero carbon economy as soon as
we possibly can do you effectively trust
the state to do this and not business no
both
it's got to be both but you talk about
de-listing companies that doesn't sound
like no let me go through it let me go
through it what we've got to do is have
state resources that will invest in the
economy alongside private sector
resources that will invest in the
economy as well
so we're looking at how do we coordinate
that what we've suggested
is a sustainable investment board that
brings together treasury the bank of
england business
the business department as well
alongside the private sector
in both in terms of businesses
themselves and trade unions
we develop our investment program and we
ensure that we use our
what powers each of us got to divert and
direct that investment
into policies and investments that will
tackle climate change but also
if there are companies that aren't
fulfilling their environmental
responsibilities
that are undermining everything that we
do putting our planet at risk
there has to be some sanctions as well
and that's regulation
some people would say that this is
government interference rather than
regulation
well government has to intervene in a
climate emergency
if we don't act now and if we allow well
if we allow some of these companies that
are developing policies that are
undermining
our very future our existence will never
be forgiven
would it be right to say that the you
know economy that you and jeremy corbyn
want to see is a capitalist one
i want to see a transformed economy so
not capitalism as it now operates i'd
like to transform the way we operate i'd
like to see that we have a
an economy in which it's working for
everybody that actually that we
we ensure that everyone shares in the
rewards so the way i've defined it
is an economy which is basically
radically fairer
radically more equal radically more
democratic
that is economically sustainable but
also is environmentally sustainable but
where the rewards
from that economy that prosperous
economy are shared by everybody is that
socialism yes
so you would prefer to replace
capitalism with social i think we're
going to evolve into
a system in which is based upon that
model
which is a democratic economy a fair
economy more egalitarian economy
but where are we all sharing that i'm
keen to talk about brexit
as well of course um now you promised
last week that we would see some white
smoke
when it came to ladies brexit it feels
like we're more in the kind of foggy
cloud
and i was hoping for that you must be
frustrated
a little bit but what happened was that
at the shadow camera two weeks ago
jeremy corbyn said that we're moving
towards a decision on this we we've all
agreed that we have to go back to the
people
yes of course we want a general election
but we have to go back to the people on
any deal or no deal
was probably in a referendum now and i'm
almost certain in a referendum
the discussion then is about what
attitude should labor take
uh and i've said publicly i i would vote
remain i'd campaign for remain
jeremy then said well we need to consult
our national executive committee members
who
the was elected by our membership who
control our party
and manage our party but also the trade
unions and that's what he was doing
he had a meeting on the the monday
before the last shadow cabinet and i
thought the next day we were going to
move further
the unions asked for a bit more time
fair enough
i don't mind that jeremy's a you know
the type of leader that jeremy is as
consensus builder and that's what he's
trying to do bring people together
have those consultations discussions and
build consensus it's been reported that
you compared labour's brexit policy to a
slow-motion car crash
i wouldn't comment on what was said in
the shadow cabinet or what was not said
i'll rephrase do you think labour's
policy is a slow-motion car crash what
i've been trying to say
is we need to move now and jeremy has
said a month ago
yes we're going to put this issue back
to the people
fully agree some feel there's been some
reporting in the papers that you know
many mps want to see a strong position
on the second referendum
yeah and actually it's the unelected
officials in the leaders office who are
resisting that now
that's you know mps are mps and
politicians and politicians it's
politicians are in control
so the issue here is we've already
agreed we're going to go back to the
people so that it's the attitude if it's
politicians who are in control
why haven't you toughened up your
position on it already because jeremy
exactly as i said is the type of leader
i completely
support and believe we need now he's a
consensus builder
but do you think then it's inevitable
that you'll go into the next election
with a position where labour backs
remain see what comes out of the
consultations that's what i'm arguing
for
and others are as well but we'll see
what comes out of those consultations
everyone should have their say whether
it's a national executive committee
member
shadow cabinet member or an affiliated
trade union we're a democracy
okay now before we go um i want to ask
you about chris williamson
um he was readmitted into the party
after saying that labour had been too
apologetic about anti-semitism
and then he was resuspended i mean it
looks like a bit of a mess doesn't it
i won't comment on any individual case
because if if you do
you're accused of pre-judging a case
chris's case will go before i think it's
back to the nec itself the disputes
committee and then the full nac will be
decided then
that's due process i remember in
hastings a year ago
asking you about anti-semitism at that
point well you know my answer i was
angry about
and i said what we need to be is faster
and more ruthless that's my attitude all
through still is are you still angry
what angers me is that um you know we
we are an anti-racist party we should be
leading the campaign against
anti-semitism in
society overall and this is holding us
back what we've got to do is move
forward now
make sure and i think the the
investigation
by the hcr will help us in doing this
whatever recommendations come out of
that we must adopt
and then hopefully then have a clean
bill of health enable us to become
that anti-racist party tackling
anti-semitism
within society overall and that's what
angers me that we've got this stain
on our society at the moment thank you
very much thank you